white house trade advisor peter navarro
will travel to ohio with the president
he joins us now peter good morning
good morning to you sir uh stimulus
package has not been announced to ohio
with the president he joins us now peter
good morning
good morning to you sir stimulus package
has not been announced the new one
negotiations remain stalled in your
estimation
where are negotiations at this point
mark meadows steve mnuchin here at the
white house leading the team up on the
hill
there seems to be uh intent on both
sides
uh to get to uh deal president trump is
the working class
president he knows the pain out there in
the heartland
uh and we're going to get this done but
but today is going to be a good day for
america on the work
front i'm going with the president on
air force one to the pride of clyde
what's beautiful about whirlpool it's
109 year old iconic american company
but it's also the poster child for how
president trump stands up
for american workers against unfair
trade because the whirlpool story
is one where they had to fight a series
of foreign predators
dumping washers into the market here all
the
dumping dumping dumping president trump
in 2018
put a 50 tariff on washers and now clyde
is booming
along with eight other locations across
america including
places like findlay and greenville and
marion in this great state of ohio
so this is going to be the great all due
respect to whirlpool when do you think a
stimulus deal
might be reached again that's
that's not my lane i'm i'm the assistant
the president for office of trade and
manufacturing what i can do is break
some news
on cbs today because the other thing
we're doing that's going to be very
important today the president is going
to sign
an executive order which is going to
deal with one of our most pressing
problems related to this pandemic
if we've learned anything in this
pandemic is that we are dangerously
dependent for our pharmaceuticals
medical supplies and equipment
on the rest of the world and
particularly with pharmaceuticals the
key starting materials
the active pharmaceutical ingredients in
the finished dosage forms
which come to us what this executive
order does it's a beautiful thing it's
pure trump
it's by american for our government
agencies like the department of defense
hhs and veterans affairs
it sweeps away some of the regulatory
barriers to traditional
manufacturing of pharmaceuticals on our
shores here
and innovation so we can keep drugs
prices down it basically pushes advanced
and continuous manufacturing technology
so this is a beautiful package
the president is going to sign it today
but i would say to the people of america
it's so important as we fight this
pandemic and
possibly future problems that we bring
our supply chains home
not just for pharmaceuticals but for all
of the critical things we need to make
this a great country
peter why the focus as these
negotiations continue why the focus on
the payroll tax cut
i'm not sure that there's a continued
focus on it that happens to be one of
the most effective ways
to get money into the pockets of the
american people if you're a worker and
there's a payroll tax cut
it's effectively a 12 percent wage
height pretty guard
that's pretty good for american workers
i think look again this is not
my responsibility or lane i have great
faith and our chief of staff mark
meadows leading this
and it looks like chuck schumer and
nancy pelosi are
between the rhetoric as they're coming
together but the mission here
is to make sure that the american people
who are out of work
uh get get relief from that and that we
also
have an economy that we can rebuild the
two things president trump
will do and this is going to be a great
speech today i urge everybody to watch
it and read it
it's it's beat the virus and and build
this economy back to where it was in
january 15th when he had built the most
beautiful and strong economy in american
history we had
three and a half percent unemployment
rate under unemployment rates at
historic lows for blacks and hispanics
rising wages for blue-collar workers
like those
in the state of ohio at places like
clyde we've got a long road a hoe here
okay make no mistake about that this
package and
it can't just be writing checks to
people now it's also got to be putting
in place
structural choices so that we can
rebuild our economy there's a bill for
example
that lindsey graham has that would bring
our
personal protective equipment back to
u.s shores
with buy american provisions those are
the kinds of things that can go into
this bill
that will help american workers and make
us safe
while the virus continues peter what did
you make of the president's comments
yesterday when he said that children are
almost immune
from the virus uh i'm not an
epidemiologist i think
i think just as a matter of fact we see
you're on the task force though uh
actually i'm not on the task force but
but be that as it may what i do my what
my job just so american people
understand
um folks like tony fauci uh they're
they're
urging people to wear masks my job is to
make sure we manufacture
enough masks i'm the the defense
production act
policy coordinator so when you have in
guilford maine
an increase in swab reduction of 20
million swabs
that's something that my office working
with the president had something to do
when we stand up
factories in five weeks basically to
make n95
mass by honeywell in arizona and rhode
island
that would be my lane so i'll leave the
leave this this that's that science uh
to to the task force
my job is to make sure the american
people have the pharmaceuticals and
protective equipment they need
all right apologies for that thanks for
that tomorrow thanks very much for your
time
pleasure to be with you this morning
anytime